yes in Lycra well I want to know where
the money's going a billion pounds yeah
I wonder if it's going to charity yeah
it's probably going to the it's probably
going to you lots probably going to
starmer or the green lot I think it
should go yeah I think it should go for
the environment but I mean it better I
would support this if they said okay
we're going to do a billion pounds and
we'll match the money as well Mark um no
Jeff Bezos he has a better record of
actually you know uh ladies and
gentlemen thank you very much indeed
that is all we have time for tonight
thank you so much adee for watching he
was at Lords he'll give you his
wonderful take on those Eco sellers
stand by my friends Piers Morgan
uncensored is next
tonight just stop all Fanatics Target
the first Ash's test of Lords only to be
hit for six by England's Johnny bairstow
Petersburg Wisconsin that an eyewitness
report of a scene of a drama me and
tonight I'll ask a couple of Eco zealots
it's all the hell they're playing at
presidential candidate Larry Elder says
he's a black Donald Trump without the
controversy there's just some pretty
controversial views of his own which
I'll put to him when he joins me live
I'll see Legendary New York pizza slice
versus Extinction in a Crackdown of
wood-fired ovens it's got even Elon Musk
fuming can the pizza man clear the smog
in the big smoke or should they just
forget about it
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is his Morgan uncensored
good evening from London welcome to
Facebook when I sent it I was at Lord's
cricket ground today the home of Cricket
the finest stadium for any sport in the
world with the longest and finest
history and I was there to witness a
master class England's Johnny bairstow
displayed his Poise his strength his
disciplined and dexterity in a
world-class performance that thrilled
supporters from both sides and one
plaudits across the globe and for those
viewing in the United States worried at
this stage this show may all be about
Cricket you might be relieved to know it
had nothing to do with the actual game
thank you
someone invaded the pitch Terry Alderman
did his shoulder in
the best though just waving to the
dressing room maybe it's his gear
tremendous stuff Johnny then turfed him
over the railing at the end like a piece
of rubbish which is exactly what he
should have done well three just stop
oil protesters rushed the pitch dead set
on ruining the Test match that they've
as they've ruined so many other National
events in the last year or so uh they
were arrested groundsmen scrubbed their
orange powder which fortunately wasn't
put on the pitch itself or he could have
wrecked the play for the entire day so
play was able to resume after just 20
minutes anyone knows Cricket will tell
you that a spot of light drizzle in a
neighboring Village could suspend a test
much longer than that so the joke in the
end was on them but what's most
impressive about this spectacle is it
one Fell Swoop Johnny bairstow trying
for countless police officers and
irritated bystanders have failed let's
take a look at an action replay
on come the protesters with their orange
powder and their teachers determined to
wreck things
but no there's no stop the oil there's
just this lift and shift the in the
wicked keeper fearing off the protester
pathetically like he's an ironing board
and dumping him like a garbage sack to
use the American vernacular and he gets
to the end I was there cheering on
Johnny Bear so Annie did the England
Captain Ben Stokes who also apprehended
one of the protesters and some of the
Australian players did too there was a
general feeling in the ground I have to
say from every player and every
spectator we're just done with these
clowns we're done with them they are
spoiled little brats attention seeking
nobody cares anymore about the message
because no one's listening
we've all just grown not just weary but
angry at the just stop oil protesters
constantly causing chaos for Chaos's
sake wrecking things that the rest of us
enjoy or just going about our normal
lives they've blocked roads they've
thrown soup over Priceless artworks
they've trashed the Chelsea flower show
they've builted themselves to the goal
post at a Premier League football match
they wrecked the World Snooker
Championship
we've all seen this stuff and just put
up with it because it's a British way
isn't it just let these people do this
because they're protesters the solution
was staring Us in the face all along it
was Johnny bairstow and the serious
Point here is that these protests have
now become completely self-defeating
many people back the principle of their
cause but not one single person at laws
today or at any of the things that
they've been doing this stuff at have
turned around afterwards and gone you
know what they've really got a point
these people and I must join their
protest after seeing them throw paint on
the pitch of the Test match
I'm not racing to be behind just stop
oil
I'm racing to loathe and to test them
for wrecking a day that I love even one
of this movement's founding fathers has
now come round to my way of thinking
about this Trevor Nielsen has been a
fortune funding climate action groups
like just stop oil now in an interview
at the weekend he said this it's
disruption for the sake of disruption
working people that are trying to get to
their job get their kid dropped off to
school survive a brutal cost living
crisis in the UK having a pink head
tattooed and pierced protesters standing
in front of their car so their kid is
late for their tests that day that
doesn't encourage them to join the
movement it's just performative it's not
accomplishing anything I absolutely
believe it's now become
counterproductive
that's the guy who's been helping to
fund just stop oil
saying exactly what I and many others
have been saying
just stop oil to change their main their
main to stop being utter pratts
well joining me now is environmental
campaigner donica McCarthy dust up World
spokesperson Chloe naldrett and the
former England uh test Cricket Legend
Sir Jeffrey boykill so welcome to all of
you well let me start with Chloe Chloe
neldre uh Chloe
even the people who are funding you
even the millionaires behind a lot of
this stuff they're sick of it the sick
of the performative stuff the attention
seeking the wrecking of stuff that other
people enjoy they recognize none of it
is turning anyone's opinion uh they're
as sick of it as I am why do you all
keep doing this
well thanks for having me on today
Pierce um what you've just done
beautiful summary of the actions that
we've been doing over the last year of
course has looked a lot at how we
protest but you haven't mentioned a word
about why why is it that a bunch of
really ordinary
community-minded
law-abiding people are taking this kind
of action and the answer is because
we're in a climate emergency and our
government is not taking it seriously
this action at Lords today isn't the
biggest climate story of the day the
biggest climate story of the day is the
fact that the government's own climate
change committee which is headed by the
conservative peer Lord Devon has found
that the government's Net Zero strategy
is failing on every single one of its
targets that means they're not keeping
us safe now and they are yeah you know
what come on shows like this and debate
that I'll invite you on to have a proper
debate about it my message
is the only way we get listen to you
that's not the only way you get on
that's a complete myth there have been
regular debates on shows like mine that
don't involve a reaction to the kind of
ridiculous nonsense we saw today the
truth is you've become a group of
Records you're just like wrecking things
for the sake of wrecking nobody is
coming along to your cause because of
these stupid stunts we all think you're
a bunch of pure old spoiled brats who
are just going out of their way to cause
other people inconvenience and ruin
their fun that is the reality you might
well have serious hang on let me finish
you might well hang on you might well
have a serious point to make or many
serious points to me I might well agree
with some of those points I probably do
but you know what the more of these
things you do are things that I enjoy
and my friends enjoy and my family
enjoys and other people with their
friends and families enjoy the more
families that you stop in getting to
work or getting their kids to school for
important exams or getting to funerals
or whatever it may be the more you do
that the more we hate you and the more
we don't want to have anything to do
with you or give you a platform to talk
about the stuff that actually is more
important as you rightly say why don't
you just stop the stupid stunts stop
wrecking because people won't wise this
won't stay in the news and it won't stay
in the conversation and perhaps what
we're doing by interrupting the things
that you need to do that are important
to you that you love is we're making you
think about everything you're making me
think you're a bunch of not Devin
said today
you're not making me think about your
calls nobody at laws today we're
thinking about it this is about climate
change we saw the orange powder the
whole crowd started booing unfortunately
England's Wicked keeper Johnny
I want to go to Jeffrey boycott Jeffrey
um you're a cricket Legend and I
remember back in my 70s a pitch being
dug up aheadingly uh which wrecked a
test match in a different kind of
protest but this this series of attacks
on stuff that most britons just like
watching the snooker the cricket the
Chelsea flower show what do you make of
it does it convince you that you should
take this kind of thing seriously
no I watched it today and I just started
laughing I thought the England players
did well and with the Aussie batsman
they made a barrier at one end for one
of them so they couldn't get through and
then the uh the staff came on and
grabbed him on Rugby tackled him Johnny
picked up the other one and the orange
powder he actually went on the ground
about eight and nine ten yards away from
the pitch yeah so he didn't do any
damage whatsoever and I just laughed I
thought it was foolish I I just thought
it was stupid there's a serious point to
this uh Jeffrey which is Hadley actually
got to the wicked itself you know these
wickets in a test match at Lords on day
one of a five-day match they're pretty
sacred pieces of land right if they got
there and begun to do actual damage to
the Wicket sprayed their paint
everywhere actually it could have
wrecked the entire test match
yes and everybody's got tickets for
tomorrow Saturday whatever whatever day
all the refunding that that absolute few
days at the cricket will be spoiled
that's what happened with the George
Davies that's what it was in 75 it was
uh some people got in through the night
they didn't have security guards then or
or dogs you know through the night to
stop that and they dug up the pitch and
they painted it and it was all about
freeing George Davis who was in jail at
the time they supposedly thought he was
wrongly put in jail and when Tony Greg
and Ian Shuffle the two captains were
walking up come to the ground early
because there's been a problem
Greggy was smart enough to Satan Chapel
can we touch a fresh pitch for you and
we'd play on that chapels of whoa we're
not stupid because as you know and any
Cricket lover knows these pictures that
they actually bat on have been prepared
and rolled and made Flat and pancake so
that you get a fair highly true bounds
if you play on a freshly known pitch the
ball Zips all over the course in
Australia with a loss so the whole
entire match was abandoned yeah that's
right it was and the whole the whole
Integrity of a of an international
cricket match say the ashes like this is
reliant on the pitch and the Integrity
of that pitch that's why it may look
like a Purell stunt actually if they got
to where they were trying to get to and
who knows what they had planned for when
they got on the Wicket they could have
raped the Lord's test match and I come
back again Jeffrey to this sense that I
had that the British public are not
getting moved one iota to support this
cause the more that they do this kind of
thing to stuff that we all enjoy
well if they got to the pitch and ruined
it in some way then there might have
been hell on they might not have got out
of the ground in one piece that's not to
say that's right but people would have
been angry that the game was ruined and
ruined for the next few days I mean this
is an ashes there isn't anything bigger
than cricket and there isn't the ground
better in the world than Lords and Mecca
of tricky yeah so it wouldn't have gone
down well and I felt at the time that's
why I laughed I thought this is silly
this is negative this is not going to do
you any good because the people are
across they're going to be mud as hell
if you ruin it I completely agree
um let me come to you then I've always
felt you're a more reasonable talker
about this kind of thing I know you've
had a long time commitment to it I want
to read you again what Trevor Nielsen
said to the Sunday Times at the weekend
it was really interesting he said I
absolutely absolutely believe this kind
of thing's become now counterproductive
I just feel like it has to be said by
somebody that was involved in the
beginning of what it's become this is
going to require an immensely difficult
navigation of the middle and the
activists are ostracizing the exact
people they need to engage they're
creating an excuse for people to stay on
the sidelines blocking Bridges is a lot
easier than Building Bridges and that is
what we need to do we're going to
succeed now I read that and I I thought
good on you good on you for not being
intransigent good on you for recognizing
what I've been saying repeatedly and
others which is it's not the cause
itself that is causing all the friction
on the problem it is the methodology of
forcing people to come along the road
with this cause and if you change the
methodology you might well bring more
people with you do you accept that no I
don't because what he's actually saying
is he's contradicting what has happened
in protest movements over the centuries
what has happened tell me one movement
that's involves systematic wrecking of
things that British people enjoy doing I
think I think the if you take a step
back and you look at the protests that
desktop all of them they've been minor
things because it's they're not minor
though they are 10 10 minutes with a bit
of dust is is minor however the the
really interesting thing about today's
protest is what it brought attention to
in the media the media this afternoon is
talking about who is sponsoring the
cricket match today it's JP Morgan JP
Morgan is the world's largest funder of
fossil fuel destruction I've not heard
anybody talking about JP Morgan it's in
the BBC it's not the guy honestly I was
at Lord's I was at Lords until six
o'clock nobody was talking about JP
Morgan or any involvement they may have
in football media today honestly I've
not seen the word read the reports in
the BBC
what they're talking about is JP Morgan
is the world's largest bank 454 billion
pounds invest in fossil fuels since
Paris and they're sponsoring today so I
think it's a really important reminder
it reminds me of the rugby projects
that's the same again and people like
you reacted to the rugby no I mean I
mean you don't know anything about what
I thought about those questions you were
responding to this protest don't
responding where's my toy Robbie I would
have people like you want to debate the
serious issues absolutely we do that
every night on the show we have a lot of
we had a big serious debate last night
about racism in Britain for example the
people involved in that debate haven't
spent the last few months running around
wrecking everything they're not a
wrecking machine they want to have a
debate which actually leads to proper
change that's what I would like to see
with your cause just stop oil everyone
now Associates just stop oil with just a
bunch of morons wrecking people's lives
that's what people like you call them I
I would actually call them Heroes
because this was heroicing
everything was said about the rugby
protest and the apartheid area let's
let's remember what's happened with the
Cricket World you talk about the
sacredness of the sport and the sequence
of the cricket pitch look at the cricket
in the world Caribbean destroyed by
hurricanes Pakistan destroyed by floods
in the extreme heat what those
cricketers are doing today is taking
their sight on the wrong side
you're saying cricketers should have
should have said stood up and Stood
Beside this stuff
no funding for new fossil fuels now this
is where you lose me this is there's a
serious debate to be had about what's
been going on in those countries I get
it I believe climate change is real I
believe it's dangerous I believe in the
core inherent
essence of your protest right I just
hate the methodology and so I can tell
you do 99 of this country and they can't
stand it I can say back to you I've been
involved in this for 30 years I spent 10
years local campaigning tenures in
politics Deputy available Democrats I've
done Camp campaigning I've done
petitions I've done marching now you're
reduced to chucking painter no I haven't
tucked paint around but you're
supporting them I'm acting support
because nothing else is worse so please
tell me we've tried politics actually
you say nothing else is worse the UK has
one of the best records in the world in
measures to combat climate change now
that is an irrefutable fact and If you
deny that you are actually denying the
very thing that you accuse other people
to do which is reality there are two
things Britain is better than the world
in in in most countries in reducing the
carbon emissions of our electricity
system everything else we're disastrous
and the most important thing about
Britain which links to today's protest
and JP Morgan Bank is we're one of the
largest funders of new
why don't you go to China
and India and Russia and pull these
stunts there why is it only the safe
places like the UK the just stop oil
chucked the stuff around at Major
sporting events and things that people
love let me tell you why because there's
a moral cowardice at the heart of what
you do it's a bit like Greta Thunder it
doesn't take Greta thundberg you never
see her in Beijing ranting away about
the Chinese government even though the
worst polluters in the world are the
Chinese so the people causing the real
damage on pollution none of your
protesters have the gumption or the
moral guts to go and wreck the lives of
those people in those countries because
you know what would happen and you pick
on the easy places who are doing the
most to try and combat it and in the
process yes you piss off the entire
country and I don't get this I mean do
you accept the point that Britain is
responsible for 15 of new funding and
philosophers globally and secondly we're
up to respond for over 50 percent
true or not here's what I accept Duke
said that's true here's what egg sets
I'm not going to quibble individual
stats because I haven't got the really
important stuff hang on I haven't got
that information in front of me what I
would say is as a broad brush stroke it
is undeniable that the UK is doing more
than most countries in the world who are
acute of the prosperous countries is
doing more to combat climate change than
most others that is a fact what I'm
agreeing with you is that we're doing
more on our electricity our own one
percent but the city of London and our
all corporations are funding that's my
advice of global admission here's my
advice so we have to protest my advice
no you don't it's the center of the
donuts come on shows like this and make
your arguments don't go and rape people
with Morgan and Barclays and shell let
me go to the final word to to Jeffrey
boycott if you're still there Jeffrey
um I want to like the low Jeffrey and
just ask you are we going to win the
ashes
no
I don't think so I think we should have
won we should have won an edge Boston we
win the game for 90 of the time yet we
lost it that's silly that is silly and
that's that's enough to cry you know
when you're winning the game 90 of the
time and you lose Australia is a good
team all right here's what I'm going to
do Jeffrey will you accept will you
accept a 100 pound bet because I say
England will win the ashes
I only bet when I'm batty
so Jeffrey it's a great honor a pleasure
to have you on the uh show I think it's
your first appearance on Piers Morgan
and says please come back again I miss
you on the airwaves still a legend still
as sharp as well great to see you and
thank you to my two uh just top oil uh
contributors uncensored next a
controversial Jewish comedian Roseanne
Barr is under Fire again it's time for
appearing to deny the Holocaust but was
that what she was really doing our free
speech and sarcasm any excuse for what
it looks like anti-Semitism or was she
really being just literally sarcastic
we'll debate that next
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Kevin just stop oil just stop stop stop
I believe in the cause I think it's a
noble cause we've got to get off carbon
fuels Save the Planet but I do believe
it's counterproductive as Trevor Nelson
I think his name is multi-millionaire
American who started funding putting
lots of money into it it's all become
performative and people aren't talking
about the issue they're talking Angry
well today was the first time Esther
I've been at one of these events as it
happened right so the start of the laws
test match the ashes it's the biggest
event in world cricket this is the most
important tournament and it's honestly
my favorite day of the year actually in
terms of sport I love it even more than
football
um and the crowd was buzzing it's been
an exciting Series so far the players
come out they've been out there for
about five ten minutes and then we knew
immediately what it was right three
idiots coming on throwing the orange
powder is just a boil and the rest of
the crowd was nobody was like go on go
on yeah I'm behind you which with every
protest there's normally some people
going I agree everyone was like oh for
God's sake yeah not them again no but
you know like that woman in the Boris
Johnson clip oh no you know like that
again and that was the reaction of the
entire crowd so this idea that this
protest is somehow changing Minds it's
it's for the birds well I mean the
people that should be most incensed by
just up oil people that are passionate
about the environment you know people
that are true environmentalists because
you're like you don't want to turn the
public against your cause and when they
make it make a mockery of a genuine
message this thing something that people
are very passionate about I think it's
really disappointing I will caution
though in protest that have been
unpopular in the past but prove right in
the long run Emily wild and Davison uh
tried to uh pin a suffragette Banner to
the king's horse yeah Derby I think it
was at 19. I think he was killed but
that was a race
I mean this is net zero is a massive
remember the Daily Mirror uh LED on you
know
protester disrupts Derby it wasn't a
noble course you know or you think of
the spring box tours in the early 1970s
upon Africa matches were disrupted by
protesters going on the pitch the fans
all booed them but they were right and
in the end they stopped the tours and
that contributed to the downfall of
white supremacy in South Africa so I am
I I think they're counterproductive now
just a while but it there is a little
bit in the back of my head others have
been said to be counterproductive in the
past I think they're preparing it to
things that are not relevant those the
examples you've given were people
fighting for rights that have been
deprived of them right they're not
fighting for the rights for people that
are they're not fighting the planet is
right no they're arguing for the for
something that hasn't been taken away
from us right if you're a suffragette
and you're arguing for the right to vote
that's something that you have illegal
you should have a legal right to for you
to tell us let's try and pressure the
public to stop using oil which was
trying to do anyway that is they are
they are fighting to end the destruction
of the planet
hit Britain but it will hit a lot of
poorer countries we live in a democracy
and we take my frustration with amazing
the guy who was at the desk key I've
talked to him a few times he's obviously
he's committed to this he believes in it
passionately he's very well informed
he's very intelligent he's like I would
love to have a normal debate with him
but every time we wheel him out it's
because these clowns have done something
stupid again and all right you might say
well okay it gets him on but we don't
get him on he doesn't really air the
proper arguments we're not really
getting anywhere it's more a defensive
thing about why he thinks they should
carry on doing it I think I think that
they if they got out and about and they
talked to people uh wider people I would
think they'd find as a hostility growing
and it's rather like the blocking roads
now if you're frustrating people going
to work or going to see their family
going to hospitals whatever it is okay
you're not concerned about you let's see
if people have persuaded me that we
should have a month-long Pride
Celebration this is London Zoo with the
animals celebrating right we've got some
footage of this I think
funny and I want to make it crystal
clear I support
Pride okay
I'm proud of pride I have always
campaigned you know as a broadcaster for
equal rights for all gay people and for
Trans people and for every other one of
those letters that increases by the week
uh but do we really need this yeah do we
yeah I love the animals at London Zoo I
take virtually signaling I take my
ground by something they know nothing
about I take my grandkids to London Zoo
all the time they always try and get you
engaged in other ways are you going to
be against Easter egg hunts London Zoo
or Christmas celebrations political
later in the week they're going to have
you know a lot of information on
conservations
in the animals why does why do only the
lgbtq one eye what I can't remember the
rest of it but why does only that group
of communities get a whole month yeah
well this is the thing I I I'm sorry I
dread pride month I think you doesn't
need to be a whole it can just be a
weekend I I don't see why we need to
have you know 30 whole days of this this
this this celebration or whatever
is absolutely everything has to be in
the rain but why yeah but there is Black
History Month now maybe London Zoo don't
do anything with that now they might
like History Month you don't go around
everywhere and everywhere is a sea okay
maybe it should what would you do on
Black they literally paint everything
black there's not there's not been
commercialized in the same way because
it actually means something maybe it
will down why don't we have veterans
month yeah you could have but why don't
we if you propose it I don't oh people
are opposed it well people have to but
what in other words why why do why do
veterans serve their country who get
wounded why don't we have a month for
them yep
all right rather non-forces day well
maybe I don't have armed forces maybe
maybe a political party or the
government or veterans themselves could
campaign for it because why do we have
pride we have pride because gay people
who used to suffer appalling bigotry and
description to some extent young still
do yeah
young people they don't need prey
because they're not everything's moved
on yeah young people don't really get
this whole sexuality thing I mean they
don't I mean for my generation it just
feels like overkillable don't be told
for a month you've got to make let
people be equal they feel it but it's
kind of moved it once it was defiant now
it's become more of a celebration all
right uh Roseanne bars is quite
interesting so she's uh in the middle of
a huge Fury in America obviously a
controversial comedian in many ways has
been canceled and so on
um she better come back and she she said
this
and nobody died in the Holocaust either
that's the truth yeah it should happen
if six million Jews should die right now
because they cause all the problems in
the world but it never happens but it
never happened right so on the face of
it utterly shocking what is she doing
she's denying the Holocaust she's saying
six million Jews should be killed the
host is laughing they should be canceled
there's just one problem that was a
severely edited clip of a satirical much
longer version in which she was actually
being heavily sarcastic and talking
about the modern Scourge where false
information
lies are mandated to be accepted by the
public by the force of social media and
so on that certain lies had no it may
have been a strange way to go about
making your point but you've got to show
it in context you can't be canceled for
something which is inherently not
accurate reflection of what she was
doing no and I agree she's Jewish 100
Jewish as she said she obviously doesn't
deny the Holocaust she's on the record
many times talking about horizontal yeah
she can be incredibly offensive as she
she was when she was canceled from a TV
show because she compared a black woman
and the Obama Administration to an ape
but here where I thought she was
particularly ill-judged is she was
basically saying there was election
election fraud and that it's a mandated
truth that there was no election fraud
when Biden beat beat Trump now you can
query that but don't then bring in the
Holocaust to that now I know she was
being sarcastic well I think I think she
was I mean that's incredibly crazy very
yeah you're right it's very poor satire
I think what she is showing though the
the in The Wider context of this is the
fact that the people that picked up on
it and just got outraged and they didn't
contextualize it for Their audience
coming under Fire the people who've LED
that who got big followers and they're
now putting out the whole thing oh by
the way this is the full car exactly
which actually when you watch it we
haven't got time to play the full
concert but when you do it's Crystal
Clear she is being sarcastic she doesn't
mean what she said there absolutely she
actually means the opposite now you may
not agree with the other point she's
making yeah but this is what I think one
of the dangers of social media really is
is that something like that gets taken
out of context and before you know it
it's gone worldwide you know via YouTube
via Twitter via Facebook via Instagram
everyone's Outreach and most people
won't ever see the in-context piece they
will just think Roseanne Barr's denied
the Holocaust before you know it boom
she's canceled yeah I mean this is the
insane world we now live in yeah but it
is fact there was a holocaust but it is
also fact the election wasn't stolen in
the US now for her to then mix the two
try and compare the two yeah it's a
poorly done but you're right she's she's
not she's not not a Mythic but you bet
if you look at social media it's a wash
yes Roseanne Barr denies the Holocaust
and that is a problem for modern society
anyway uh great to see you both thank
you very much indeed I won't ask you a
few of you of the ashes although it's
like either of you do you like Ricky I
love Cricket I like the last three days
I'm literally obsessed with the ashes
obsessed with Cricket but and I love
myself it's a lonely old world Lords is
the best ground but uh in a way all the
route there's two wickets at the end I
was thinking maybe it was a shame on the
wickets and delays I was actually
sitting today with Andre chefchenko the
who's uh actually got a massive game the
football legend we've got a massive
football match charity game for Ukraine
coming up on August the 5th so it was
the one that I interviewed Alexander
zinchenko the Arsenal player about the
two of them are captaining teams August
the 5th Stanford Bridge an amazing cause
game for Ukraine thank you both very
much thank you uh so it's the next
presidential candidate Larry Elder has
been called a black Donald Trump without
the controversies these may be
controversial so I'll put him to the
test next
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
this is talk TV
[Music]
well with former president of Donald
Trump's legal woes mounting perhaps a
small wonder that no fewer than 12
Republicans so far have lined up to
challenge him for the presidential
nomination we'll hear from one at the
moment but Democrats of course have a
Biden shape problem of their own here is
the leader of the Free World forgetting
which war he was talking about earlier
today
has Vladimir Putin been weakened by
recent events it's hard to tell but he's
clearly losing a war in Iraq he's losing
the war at home and he is uh become a
physical prior around the world
okay it's not a war in Iraq obviously
it's a war in Ukraine you'd think the
president United States might know that
but this is the same president United
States who has made a habit lately of
both verbal and physical gaffes let's
take a look
[Applause]
all right God Save the Queen man
it has Vladimir Putin been weakened by
recent events it's hard to tell but he's
clearly losing the war in Iraq he's
losing the war at home
so all that has happened quite recently
I'm joined Now by Larry Elder one of the
12 Republican Presidential hopefuls uh
Larry great to talk to you again it's
been quite a while I think the last time
I talked to you you were calling me a
stupid idiot live on air so I hope we
can have a more civilized conversation
and and and and vice versa I might add
uh it's great to see you and
congratulations on your on your bid to
be present let's talk about President
Biden first it seems to me barely a day
goes by now without some new
embarrassment either involving his
physical Mobility with him falling over
and tripping and so on uh or perhapsible
worryingly the constant verbal gas and
sometimes they're trivial like when he
said God Save the Queen man appearing to
forget the queen died nine months ago
and he was at the funeral
um but sometimes today when he's talking
about the Ukraine war to actually
mistake it for the Iraq War you know
last year he was kind of rewriting
American foreign policy in with Taiwan
and so on with his missteps which has to
be corrected by the White House if you
put it all together I wrote a column for
the New York Post about this which
resonated quite big yesterday that you
put it all together there's a clear
suggestion here that the president of
the United States is not in full control
of his faculties
I I agree with you uh and as you pointed
out some of these are kind of trivial
some of them can be written off as
gaffes but some of them cannot for
example he was recently at Howard
University and he said the biggest
threat to the American Homeland was
white supremacy I mean my goodness uh
the Anti-Defamation League peers keeps
track of how many people are killed by
extremists no matter the color of the
extremists and last year there were 25
however in 2020 there were 11 nearly 11
000 black homicide victims almost all
killed by other black people to my
knowledge none killed by a so-called
white supremacist so this is kind of a
lie that infects America that really
hurts this country and that is one of
the reasons I'm running not only that
Joe Biden is opposed to school choice
Pierce is an absolute crisis in urban
America as to our government schools
Chicago 53 government schools were zero
percent I kid you not zero percent of
the kids can do math and grade level
Baltimore 13 public high schools zero
percent of the kids can do math at grade
level another half a dozen where uh only
one person can that's half of all the
public high schools in Baltimore all
located in the inner city and this lie
that that Biden and the others push
about America being systemically racist
has murderous consequences
currently you're polling one percent on
the Democrat side right so it's it let's
be honest it's highly unlikely you are
going to be the next president of the
United States doesn't mean you shouldn't
be running and you can't make all these
points but we both know it's it's highly
unlikely it's going to likely be either
Joe Biden who said he is running and if
he's the incumbent president that means
he'll run and there's something
extraordinary was to happen and on the
Republican side Donald Trump obviously
is way ahead right on your side so what
is going to happen here I mean Donald
Trump wins the Republican nomination
many people think he can't win a
national election against somebody who
most people think is completely out of
it isn't it sensible for the Republicans
to find a candidate that actually is not
Donald Trump who would probably have a
very easy time beating Joe Biden
uh shockingly Pierce I agree with you I
believe that there are so many swing
voters in swing States who would not
vote for Donald Trump if the man walked
on water in fact if he did they'd accuse
him of not being able to swim now I
think at some point as did the Democrats
back in 2020 uh Republican voters are
going to realize they need to coalesce
behind somebody whose last name is other
than Trump but for whom a sufficient
number of Swing voters can can vote so
that we can win in November 2024 and I
want to get up there on that debate
stage in Milwaukee I need 40 000
individual donors you can give as little
as one dollar to get me up there on that
debate stage at the very least you'll
get a America First candidate of make
America great again candidate who will
talk about the live systemic racism talk
about the vital need for school choice
uh in America and the ten thousand pound
elephant in the room that nobody's
talking about and that is the epidemic
of fatherlessness seventy percent of
black kids ended the world today without
a father in the home married to the
mother up from 25 back in 1965. you
can't tell me America is more racist
today than it was in 65. what's happened
is the welfare state that the left push
beginning in the 60s that is in advise
women to marry the government and
incentivize men to abandon their
financial and more responsibility at the
very least if I can put these issues
front and center I will feel that I've
done a service to my party and more
importantly peers I will feel that I've
done a service to my country yeah I I
actually agree with you I think it's
absolutely right that people like you
should run and you should raise the
issues which are important so so we're
both so we're both we're both agreeing I
agree with you you agree with me Love Is
in the Air that's not good too hasty
here uh Larry but on a final point
should Donald Trump even be allowed I
mean obviously he's allowed to legally
but should he be allowed to run as a
candidate for president now that he's
got two indictments and is likely to
face at least one maybe two more
I would put that question to you should
Joe Biden be allowed to run it is
obvious uh he's got major major trouble
and we know from these whistleblowers
from the IRS that the uh that the
investigation uh was roadblocked uh
we've got evidence that Joe Biden was on
the take for maybe five million dollars
for policy decisions in favor of Ukraine
uh and barisma as far as I know he isn't
even being prosecuted there's a
two-tiered system of justice in this
country and I don't see why Donald Trump
should be held accountable when Hillary
and Joe Biden are not well I think they
should all be held accountable but they
should all be treated equally and they
should all be treated exactly in the
same way and on that point I agree with
you uh Larry good to talk to you let's
end it before we ruin it and start
abusing each other it's great to have
you back on on the show and we'll talk
again another time good luck to you and
thank you for not and thank you for not
calling me the black face the white
supremacy yesterday the Los Angeles
Times any day when I'm not called that
is a good one I'm just going to stick to
calling you Larry I think it's a lot
safer
thank you sir I appreciate it it's like
yeah Larry Ellen good to talk to you
well on since the next a legendary New
York pizza slice is under threat amid a
Crackdown on wood-fired ovens it's to
raise everyone right up to Elon Musk the
city says it will clear the polluted air
the citizens say save our slice that
debate is next
[Music]
laughs
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
perfect
coming up on the talk Daniel corski
quits the race to become London mayor
following groping allegations cricketer
Johnny bairstow Halls Eco protesters off
the pitch at Lords and we're talking
about middle class micro dosing as it's
reported Elon Musk takes cataman for his
mental health that's all at nine o'clock
[Music]
New Yorkers are being asked to choose
between planet and pizza at City Hall
because Force pizzerias to install
Emissions Control devices on their coal
and wood-fired ovens to improve air
quality critics say that will cost a lot
of dough boom boom and may even ruin the
flavor of the legendary New York slice
this is enraged locals
one man turned up at the mayor's office
to throw pizzas over the fence in
protest Shannon give us pizza or give us
death the famous pizza reviewer Dave
Portnoy has vented his rage
apparently in New York City
some little liberal arts ivy league
pink-haired crazy liberal who's never
worth one day in the real world is on an
environmental commission and they woke
up from their little nappy poo wherever
that may be like I figured out how to
save the world today
Dave's not happy is he well even Elon
Musk who's Tesla electric cars are a
massive Aid in fighting global warming
tweeted this is utter BS it won't make a
difference to climate change but joining
me now live from his New York pizza
restaurant is Paulie G and I'm also
joined by the editor of the heated
newsletter Emily Atkin okay well look
this is a heated debate in many ways
Paulie let me start with you uh I've got
some pizza here I love pizza I love
coming to New York and having a slice
over there I know exactly how it's made
I like the way it's made and I'm with
Elon Musk I don't think he's going to
make any difference this initiative to
combating climate change what is your
view though as a pizza man in New York
you may have to potentially face
tripling Financial penalties because of
this
well small Pizzeria small business
owners are being asked to put these
devices on uh I put my device on uh in
2019. we were supposed to have this done
by 20 January 2020 that uh never came
through but I'm happy that I did because
my flu is near an apartment building
right next to me and the smoke that was
coming out when we started the fire or
when we threw Another Log on the Fire
you know it was disturbing my neighbors
and I didn't want to do that I didn't
want to spend twenty thousand dollars
but I did and I'm glad I did but you
know now
businesses after the pandemic I think
you'll find that most small businesses
like mine are not doing as well as they
did before
okay so this is interesting so broadly
speaking so broadly speaking Paulie what
you mean is you kind of agree with the
principle of this but the cost may just
be too bright I agree I agree in
principle that that that it's it's good
for air quality in New York yeah it's
certainly the the mayor compared the
smoke that comes out of 100 of these
ovens uh to the smoke that came out of
the fires in Canada and made it
practically impossible to see across the
city and if that was the case with these
100 ovens why can we look across and see
a beautiful beautiful Skyline well that
is a good point so Emily Atkin look we
started this uh show tonight with the
just stop oil protests in the UK which
is a similar theme about fossil fuels
and the emissions and so on why Target
pizza slices in New York
well it's interesting I'm not really
here to talk about the merits of the
rule or debate whether it's a good idea
or not my real thing that I've been
trying to put forward is to have people
understand that despite how it's been
characterized
this rule isn't intended to solve
climate change I myself took a look at
the proposed rule when I saw the the
first New York Post report about this
I'm a journalist myself so I care about
the facts I'm also a New Yorker and I um
paid for my college tuition by at a SUNY
school by working at a pizzeria so I
care very much about this
um and I didn't see the words climate
carbon or carbon emission one time so
I've been very concerned with how this
has been described as a rule to solve
climate change when it doesn't really
appear that that's what it is it's a
it's a rule
to reduce particulate emissions for
exactly for the neighbors that
um Paulie was just talking about you
know it's interesting I I had what I
thought was regular bad allergy issues
which I thought were hay fever and then
six months ago someone pointed out to me
that I live in a very heavily polluted
part of London one of the worst in the
country in the UK and advise that I get
some air purifying machines in my house
and not go out if a air quality app said
it was really bad out there so I did
both things and I've had zero allergy
problems really pretty much in the last
six months for the first time in many
years so I completely sign up to this
pollution issue the question I guess uh
Paulie is can you divorce the two things
I mean heavy pollution clearly many
people believe that is a contributory
factor to the general issue around
climate change the future of the planet
and so on
100 pizza ovens that operate part of the
day is that going to cause the kind of
pollution that we're talking about there
are many other things that cause that
type of pollution and you know and
the government is willing to subsidize
efforts to improve that and a perfect
example is the ferry that's about two
blocks from my Pizzeria here the New
York City Ferry charges about four
dollars per ride to people and they did
a study and the cost of operating that
is over ten dollars a ride so that that
method of reducing emissions is being
subsidized they're asking small
businesses uh who again you know thanks
to the pandemic we're really not doing
as well as we were and costs are going
up even on these devices we have to put
on right I spent twenty thousand dollars
right now it's almost twenty five
thousand yes but there's you know this
is an unfunded mandate yeah it's a lot
of money Emily if you were running the
country and let's face it you probably
couldn't do a worse job uh right now but
if you were running the country what
would be the what would be the main
thing you would want to do
immediately to achieve what you would
like to achieve with the planet
I mean if I were running the country we
would certainly have a very different
country but I generally don't even think
about that because I am a journalist
right like this is my what I am super
passionate about is making sure that
we're having fact based debates
um and I think that this debate in
particular has been sort of warped to be
about something that it's not about
improving overall air quality in the
city which it's sort of about but not
really about about about solving climate
change which it's not really about okay
about this very uh it's about this very
specific thing
flowing into your neighbors I think you
made the uh I think we've run out of
time that's why I'm cutting I'm sorry
it's a really interesting debate thank
you both for joining me I think you're
kind of right actually both of you
um which is a strange way to end the
debate but I do thank you both very much
whatever you're up to uh keep it
unpolluted and keep it uncensored
thank you
[Music]
foreign